somewhere inside your head somewhere
inside the seemingly impossible
organization
of electrically charged meat that calls
itself the brain
is you you nor anyone else properly
understands how this you comes to be
how states of chemicals and electrical
firings turn into your immensely complex
subjective self fundamentally you
don't understand you where you come from
or how you work
and yet it is the same you that is
trying to manage all of the complexities
of being a you
in the world and for the most part
trying to be liked
by all the other yous that it encounters
of course it feels very nice to be liked
in certain cases
it is essential our well-being depends
to some degree
on the quality of our social relations
which require us being sufficiently
liked by at least some people
some amount of the time the impulse
desire to be liked and the concern we
have over what others think of us
has clear sociological and evolutionary
purpose to cooperate effectively
reproduce cultivate a sense of belonging
and so on
the problem however is the tendency for
this otherwise positive impulse
to grow and mutate into a state of
malignancy
how often do we find ourselves worrying
about what others will think of us
before entering into a benign low-stakes
social interaction
how often are we worrying while we are
in one how often do we worry about
others thinking about some strange or
foolish
but otherwise harmless thing we said or
did in the past
how often are we doing or not doing
things buying or not buying things
trying or not trying things because of
our concern over how others we don't
barely know or aren't barely affected by
will see us any and all of these common
cases
is where the concern over what others
think of us can obviously turn
potentially malignant in infancy and
early childhood
we are inadvertently conditioned by our
parents teachers and so forth
to feel like we are the center of all
attention the most important thing in
the world and beyond
everything we do is relevant
consequential or impressive
when we walk for the first time it's the
most important thing that could have
happened in the world that day
if we draw on the wall it's the worst
thing but of course
the world did not care about either of
those things that day at all
as we age and are further socialized
into the world we slowly but surely
realize this
that the world mostly has never and will
never care about what just about anyone
does
the vast majority of the time including
us
we are not really at the center of
anything at all not even our own mind
we are not important in any grand sense
no one really cares
not really not in the way that we want
this becomes obvious when we turn our
lens away from our self
and toward how we view others how often
and how long do we think or care about
others we don't know that well
how much do we care about the mistakes
missteps and quirks of those we do
how often are we thinking closely about
what others are saying or doing in the
moment
or in life broadly how often does it
affect them even if we are
surely there are some exceptions here in
certain circumstances with certain loved
ones
friends colleagues and so forth but for
the most part
the answer is likely very little if not
not at all
we are all so worried about ourselves we
leave almost no time or mental space to
worry about others in anywhere near the
same way we are concerned
and so likewise most of the time when we
do or don't do something in a social
moment
or in life in general and we are
concerned that others will perceive us
negatively
most are in fact too busy concerning
themselves with when they messed up
or how they look to ever notice us let
alone care
on one hand confronting this how little
others really care or think about us
takes away some degree of our sense of
importance but on the other hand
it gives us the potential freedom to
worry less about what others think
and focus more on what we do in his
famous 20th century play
no exit french existentialist
philosopher jean-paul sartre wrote
you remember all we were told about the
torture chambers the fire and brimstone
the burning marl old wives tales there's
no need for red-hot pokers
hell is other people this line hell is
other people
it's perhaps one of sartre's most famous
quotes as well as one of his most
misinterpreted
he is not suggesting here that other
people are inherently evil
or bad or unlikable but rather that hell
is the imposed state of dependence and
modification of oneself
according to the integration approval
and satisfaction of other people's
perception
for sartre we naturally identify our
sense of self through what he referred
to as the look
which essentially refers to the gaze or
perception of other people we encounter
in a sort of self-reflective function of
consciousness sartre argued that a full
comprehension of ourselves
forms as a result of our perceiving that
we are being perceived
by others he would refer to this
construction of self
as the other in this in every encounter
with another person
even if we are not conscious of it we
become some level aware that others
like us are constructing their own
worlds and their own versions of us
rendering us into objects of their
perception as a consequence
since we are in part comprehending
ourselves through the reflective
function of this
we yearn for that reflection of us to be
of high esteem and value
and modify ourselves accordingly sartre
suggested however that in the process of
trying to fashion ourselves according to
how we fit into the look or minds of
other people
we deviate from our free personal and
subjective self
and in doing so enter into a state of a
sort of existential hell
[Music]
and needing other people's approval of
ourselves so badly
we relinquish ourselves in the process
moreover
if one is not actually like something
does not like something
and so on but acts as if they do they
are giving off a false impression to
those they portray it to
all while harboring an entirely
different truth that will either die
inside them
or grow and fester into some eventual
external explosion
unfairly putting those who were not
given the right information right in the
line of debris
ultimately the truth is of course no
matter who you are
and what you do some people will not
like you just like how you
won't like some people because everyone
is some amount
unlikable we are all messes hovering
around inside these obscure brains
trying our best to try our best tripping
up on every third step
we are not the calm cool collected types
of people we draw up in the ideal
even on the highest thrones in the world
we are still sitting on our ass
wrote montagna and so ultimately if
we're going to look weird or be unliked
when we worry about what others think
and attempt to mold ourselves
accordingly
you might as well be weird and unliked
just going about yourself as you are
as best you can although it's easy to
agree with this conclusion
that of course does not mean the actions
that follow are
arguably to stop worrying about what
others think of you in this sense
is not the kind of thing that can easily
be trained or rationalized away
when the anxiety of disappointment or
rejection comes into play
during various life choices when the
self-aware anxiety hits in the moments
of certain social interactions
the uncontrollable state of mind that
occurs seems to struggle to see order
self-control and rationality one can
know all of the aforementioned to be
true
that in most cases it generally doesn't
matter what others think of you
that your life is lived and experienced
through your own mind in your own mind
alone
but just like an irrational fear of a
harmless spider irrational anxieties of
harmless social relations and
interactions
by definition don't respond well to what
you rationally know
if there is to be some particular
mindset that might help though it
perhaps starts with these subtle
reminders
reminders of whatever helps regain
perspective over how little others care
how little the world cares how absurd it
is to be and function as what you are
and that any moments of clarity coolness
and success when they come
are to be appreciated for what they are
unusual heroic transcendences
to the norm of the human condition if
like sartre suggests
we see ourselves by being seen by others
or like how charles cooley put it
i'm not who you think i am i'm not who i
think i am
i am who i think you think i am then
perhaps we must see how other people see
carefully and as generously as possible
this video was sponsored by brilliant
for many the intimidation difficulty and
or tediousness of subjects in math and
science can make it hard to start or
sustainably pursue learning
on your own the problem-solving website
and app brilliant
however help solve this problem for you
by providing affordable convenient
interactive and effective learning
courses in math
science and computer science brilliant
helps eliminate the barriers to entry
and makes it easy to start enjoy learn
and excel
in stem subjects brilliant 60 plus
courses utilize newly enhanced
digital interactives puzzles and
storytelling
that provide engaging learning
experiences that are responsive and
corrective
in real time by actually interacting and
playing with various problems and models
you not only learn the information with
brilliant but also understand its
application on a more fundamental level
seeing as how the best way to learn is
generally by doing not just showing
brilliant provides the perfect resource
for anyone interested in anything from
developing their logic and reasoning
skills
learning statistics algebra physics
machine learning
finance and much more if you enjoy brain
teasers to enhance your critical
thinking and problem solving skills
brilliant has several excellent courses
including the joy of problem solving
which challenges you to use your
creativity and intuition to notice
patterns
create proofs and solve puzzles related
to logic and algebra
if you're interested in joining
brilliant you can go to brilliant.org
pursuit of wonder or click the link in
the description below to sign up for a
free
trial the first 200 people will also get
20 off their annual premium membership
and of course thank you so much for
watching in general and see you
next video
[Music]
you